all right so we got Thomas here let's
see Dr sherbet Nico Jesse in the house
cat man welcome cat man
and then we said we also called out
portero protero in the house uh Kathy
Channel member is here I agree Jake
winter is absolutely beautiful my
favorite season hands down hands down my
favorite season in Hogwarts Legacy for
sure
Adept legitimans really love the main
story had all the mystery and excitement
that I loved about the books
I liked it too uh I don't want to talk
about it too much yet
I still feel like for overall story
spoilers I feel like about a two week
period is kind of a good
kind of a good range to give people
before you so I mean I'm not going to be
going out of my way to talk about story
spoilers tonight so most of what I'm
going to be doing is probably
I mean there will be spoilers but it's
going to be non like not Major Spoilers
you know because I'm not gonna be um
I've beaten the story I have beaten the
main story saw someone asking about that
as oh a Super Chat yeah yeah
so we also had Jesse with the super chat
if he finished the game yeah I did
finish the game
I think I still have one
final cut scene because I did not get
the credits yet but I'm pretty sure I I
beat like the final boss and everything
so
thank you so much for the Super Chat
Jesse and then per Barthel with a super
chat as well I didn't see a comment
without per bar though but I I recognize
your name always showing love and
support very much appreciate you being
here tonight
very much appreciate it and then also
Jesse with another Super Chat hope you
feel better soon yeah I'm feeling a lot
better I I really am thank you I'm
feeling a lot better but just my eye
looks terrible it looks absolutely
terrible
but yeah like churning out all this
content then being sick
it's just been a lot at once a lot at
once
I I have kind of a um
this might be a bit of a hot take a bit
of a hot take here chat
you guys ready for this
I think people play video games too fast
I just can't get over how fast people
are beating this game
I'm like guys we've been looking forward
to this to two and a half years and you
just knocked it out in two days
which I mean if that's how you enjoy
games go for it go for it but like
Nico was asking me the other night Nico
100 of the game already
yeah I'm gonna call you out Nico I'm
calling you out how like I even got the
game early nowhere close to 100.
I just want to like sit down it's like
when you sit down and have a fine meal
you know
like if I'm just going to McDonald's or
somewhere fast food yeah get in get out
be done
but like when I have something that I've
just been looking forward to and waiting
for so like literally years oh man I
just want to savor it and it has made it
harder like with making content not that
I'm complaining about it but like you
have you know you got to be at a certain
point to be able to keep making content
about the game
but I'm just I'm literally blown away at
how fast people are uh going through
this man
I'm nowhere close to 100 and I'm still
nowhere close to like even completing
all the quests but I was telling Nico's
like I played all like I had all the
pre-release time that I played
then I had the times on stream which
I've noticed
the times on stream are a little bit
weird because a lot of times I'm doing
stuff that like chat wants to see or I'm
answering chat questions so you don't
get to like plow through as quickly as
you normally would
leading to hogsmeade but I haven't found
it but
um
hold on
oh I gotcha
I had a text my wife sometimes texts me
when things are going wrong on stream
had to make sure it wasn't from her
yeah so I put all that time in the time
on stream and then Saturday I was just
like okay this is getting ridiculous now
I got the game early and people people
already beaten the game I gotta just I
literally guys like I played the whole
day Saturday played the whole day
and I still hadn't beat the game it's
like I guess I'm just doing too many
side quests I get I guess I'm just going
off the beaten path here
I don't know dude I'm just I'm just
taking my sweet time with the game
and now like now that I've beaten it I
hope that I like at least I've beaten
the main story I hope I can settle into
this of of just hanging out and enjoying
the game now and like because 100 I
don't care I'm gonna get it I'm 100
going to get it but I don't care how
fast I get it I'm just gonna take my
time try to enjoy it
all right let me catch up with the chat
here now as well Nate uh Nate Nate is
natist native stay I don't know how to
say that
TG in the house as well
uh let's see cat man here Templar gaming
got one of the gifteds Brittany L is
here Brittany always wins our uh
Harry Potter quote trivia
dude this man right here oh it's a
different kid
it's a different kid but like the first
day that I started there was a kid just
just waiting right here
and he was just moving like he or he
wasn't moving he was just just just
chilling like this
come on dude just say something oh did
we get a little like a grunt of
annoyance there at least say something
oh we did we did there
all right so this is one of the most
important side quests in the game I
think right here with with our boy
Gladwin so we're probably gonna be
working on that some tonight I want to
see how many I have here
I love his voice too
okay
I need to work on my impression I've
been a little under the weather so it's
harder it's hard to get my voice just
right but oh greetings any luck removing
some of them more some more of those
Demi guys statues it's kind of like you
gotta like get this oh great things we
also had burnouts and bourbon with the
Super Chat found your channel just this
week just wanted to say appreciate the
work and info Insight cheers from KY
burnout to Berman thank you so much for
the Super Chat
for the love and support yeah it's been
really it's been a quite a fun ride
covering this game
quite a fun ride appreciate you stopping
by we do these live streams every
Tuesday we also stream over on Twitch as
well
Onyx BTW got 100 at 41 hours how
how
I I just I don't see how that's possible
not saying not saying that you didn't do
that but like the my play style I have
no idea how that's possible
like zero idea
zero idea let's see the flash got one of
the GIF uh GIF gift hits we got JP in
here tonight as well
let's see who else is here in the house
oh man I've got to scroll back up now
all right catching up catching up okay
there we go
uh Alicia yeah I finally bought the
little thing that automatically feeds
people yeah I actually have some Moons
for you yeah I do have some yeah they
have some Moons for you we're getting
close
colors
what's that I don't think I've ever
asked him where can I find why should
they look for more damage I mean I know
where but all of my usual haunts which
as you know have now become quite horny
he's so different from fields
some of the surrounding amulets sure but
I did get another niffler if not Sarah
left the castle in ages
all right bud I'll keep looking for you
I'll keep an eye out for division
thinking for the two months dude retro
my friend cheers to your amazing success
have a great stream
ER how long straight from the dark guard
at night I'm already ready for another
playthrough with dark arts I did on this
one though I'll show you this or
Division I did a
I talked about this in my video today so
like the talents even if you're not
gonna go dark arts like don't just
ignore these which I guess some people
could you could argue these are
technically dark arts too but
likes some of them don't require the
unforgivables I was surprised to see
this I hadn't even looked in here I
hadn't even looked at this tab at all
and then somebody mentioned
I think it was in one of the live
streams or it might have been on a
YouTube comment and a video somebody
said something about this and so sure
enough I go in and yeah you can actually
put a curse effect on Expelliarmus on
flopindo this one stupefies a really
handy one right here here's the one that
lets them share damage
you can even put it on Aristo momentum
and then uh let's see what else cursed
effect remains on enemy for a longer
period of time so there and yeah there's
the pindo so it's really like only these
four I guess
that up oh wait that one actually
defeating a cursed enemy restore some of
your health oh my gosh see that's not
that doesn't apply
require the unforgivables either that
one does
then we had striking an enemy curves by
crucial release the project okay that
one does
and then that one does as well
when did I get your Beastie I have no
idea I don't know which I don't know
which one's the last one
I do have the grab horn but I don't
think that's the last one I I don't
think grab horns are the last one
yeah we got the lord of the shore
I guess we could put him in the vivarium
too
uh then Jesse with a super chat I think
we already answered that one about
asking um
oh Murphy Aslan
Murphy Asian I think
oh Murphy see I told you guys I'm having
eye trouble
having eye trouble blur blurred vision
too there
blurred vision
got the five gifteds potato Steely what
do you what are you stealing what do you
stealing portero it's been so uh I I get
so behind in the chat this is kind of
what happens over here on YouTube man I
get so far behind
so now I'll ask you what you're what
you're talking about you're stealing and
then by the time I get up to it it'll
just be completely
I'll I'll have to ask you again
look at all these presents rolling in
look at all the presents I've got
presents
presence presence presence
feel like you level up so fast I have
not played the haunted hogsme Duck shirt
but that's actually a great
a good one for a stream I think
Catman you posted like three times
you've heard I'm a good rapper
so you must know me from my high school
days or you know someone who knows me
from high school
oh yeah people asking about the robe too
the robe is
the robe is Merlin it was the exclusive
twitch drop from Avalanche
my wife's texting me answers to my
questions he wants to steal oh the
massage idea for a birthday gift thank
you Mr Dragon tour yeah
right it's such a good joint gift
such a good joint gift
you both enjoy it it's like really
relaxing
but yeah dog Sherman I think that's a
great idea hardcore Paul welcome be at
Merlin robe I keep I keep gravitating
back to it although I've heard I've
heard guys let me go into my
Quest I've heard that the dedalian keys
Quest
you know what might start with that one
we might start with the deedalian keys
because I've heard that the reward for
this is really nice
and then we had when zero zero with the
Super Chat as well are you going to
upload a let's play to YouTube okay so
anytime we play
the game live like we are right now on
YouTube it will
see it's just like it doesn't really
show up I guess unless you go out here
it does and it doesn't but the very
first time we played this game on stream
we streamed it on YouTube so it's
already up on the channel you just have
to go back through our lives
which is like a different Tab and you
can find it there all right I'm chat I'm
really gonna have to figure out how to
play and read read chat at the same time
because I realize I'm just standing in
one place and without my face on screen
to like you know talk and interact with
you
just having my character stand in one
place I don't feel like is is good
viewing I don't feel like it's good
entertainment
although hold on I might want to stop
right here because
oh here we go I like this we got some
good music right here all right I'm
gonna catch up on chat and then we're
gonna play then we're gonna play
you tell people I'm a boxer I know right
took your tip to turn off the minimap
forcing you to play slower next door
yeah like I've seen so many people when
I watch gameplay and the mini map is on
it a thousand percent makes things
easier it really does
and when I start going for like all the
little Collectibles and stuff I'll
probably just turn it on but my first
playthrough I don't regret it at all I
think it was way more
just way more enjoyable
oh I'm just now getting to the point
where I called out Nico yeah I'm way
behind Kathy you're getting really close
to 100 leave I-40 hours and only 52. see
that's where I feel like Levi I'm kind
of right there with you I'm just a
little bit over 40 hours and what was I
so 60 on the challenges I'm level 32.
like I just I mean if you're purely
optimizing like only to beat the game
and do everything like maybe I could see
how you do it somebody was saying they
did it on 40.
uh Kevon Thompson I don't know not
analyzing the things around you is fun I
don't know how not analyzing things
Rodney's fun never have chill play
what's that's what's wrong in the
community I'm not sure you may be
talking about people going too fast
Maybe
played like 14 hours and at ten percent
hello Jake currently at winter theme
just started to explore 30 hours in slow
down to get to know the world Benjamin
says Hey Benjamin
Benjamin one of the developers I believe
is that is that the same Benjamin I
think it is there's so much people have
missed even with 100
there Benjamin that's all I needed to
hear dude haven't seen anyone discover
all the secret interactions of the
fireflies or get all versions of the
busker b-u-s-k-e-r
I'm not sure what that is b-u-s-k-e-r
I'm gonna have to look that up though
see that's the period I'm looking
forward to getting into now Benjamin
like
I I just like people just devoured it
they just devoured I can't imagine what
it's like for you guys you know this
five six years of your life and then
people devoured in two days
nature guy almost 100 of the trophies
just need to play the other three houses
yeah I want to do that too
dude this area is kind of cool actually
all these instruments going on which by
the way the little traveling bard
he plays this instrument right here I've
seen him with both of these he has that
little snake
but he only does it like he adds
instruments if you keep donating to him
so whenever you see that guy
make sure you donate to them
marvolo close to 100 as well can you go
into other common rooms uh pretty sure
no TG
marvolo you put like 87 okay there you
go Benjamin calling us out I mean like I
I guess I'm the one who started it right
because I said I feel like people are
just going through way too fast
and it's just like I just it blows my
mind oh you already got that one
thank you
trial 3 was incredible dude there are so
many epic moments so many epic moments
Adept 44 hours in main story done Quest
6067 out of 69 done Field Guide 70
percent
sir Dallas still have hey don't feel bad
sir Dallas take your time Tyler how's it
going welcome we got princess here as
well princess how's it going
oh it just did the thing where it jumps
way forward in the chat there we go
there we go I'm caught up now
oh don't hate on glad when Alicia
Gladwin is awesome
do you feel weird wearing the crazy
clothes as a student okay so I mentioned
this on a previous stream
I'm gonna mention it again so when I
went for the early preview and got to
play one of the things that the game
director Alan two one of the things that
he told me
is he told me that there are certain
outfits that you can be wearing
that students will comment on
now I don't know if it's in class or if
it's just when you're walking by I don't
know how the commenting works and I
don't know which outfits there are
but
that's what he told me so there you go
now people are people need to try to
find all the little uh
all the the special outfits I I feel for
sure I feel like one of them has to be
the night outfit right I put that one on
the other day and tried to get it to
trigger something
cause I feel like that one is just
oh hearing the little uh chime
could be below me though or it could be
above me as well
you store have finished today with
Hogwarts Legacy it was fire is so good
Heidi welcome thank you for being here
Nico's hooky 66 hours spent a lot of
time walking places instead of running
or flying
66 hours in how many days
Nico how many days
I just
man maybe it's a sign I mentioned this
last time maybe I'm too old now dude
like maybe I just can't have those
gaming sessions like I used to but I
played all day Saturday I was like oh
Saturday is it I'm get I'm getting
through it for sure today for sure we're
beating the game Saturday nope
no
didn't happen
but 66 hours that you know that sounds
fairly reasonable but you said you were
walking a lot of places too
oh Arthur what's up dude all right did I
get the Unicorn yet no have not gotten
that one
okay now I just caught up to protero's
comment about the massage idea so many
lovely presents retro dude how you gonna
change your name to that that's TG isn't
it I think that's TG you changed their
name
uh I've done two of the three battle
arenas that might be another good one to
do on stream adept
might be another good one to do
investigated the rumors of the bainber
Hamlet I have not Benjamin I have not
Dr sherbet with the four months wouldn't
recommend getting started with the
hogsmead mission oh wait I would
recommend streaming hogsmeade oh with
camera ah gotcha
you got the detailing keys and worth the
rest of the game
see I'm so far behind somebody saying go
to the picture
uh boy black boy with the e at the end I
played 74 hours in five days oh my
goodness
yeah I still have the dark arts me store
I still do I still have the dark arts uh
you talking about the Cosmetic
be you as well ignatia
all right I know I'm just wandering guys
I'm just wandering
I'm almost caught up I'm almost caught
up
uh protero dumb question if you can't go
into the commons room can you at least
find yes you you can find the entrance
mm-hmm
yep
Alicia hating on glad when so
disappointing
so disappointing Alicia
they comment when you wear the pajamas
Jack Attack says there we go there's one
there's one April how's it going welcome
we got GG in the house as well
America
Funk f-u-n-k I'm gonna say that very
enunciate that very clearly Funk yeah
hello from Kentucky hey there thanks for
stopping by we have Pale Rider how about
where the armor in front of the Circa
Duggan
oh that's a good idea
Rob says you can glitch your way into
other common rooms interesting
all right and we are caught up Jake just
figured out I've only been playing 17
hours
exactly marvolo that's that's why I want
to do this one okay so I'm locked in now
Chad I'm locked in I know I've just been
wandering aimlessly if you're just
tuning in wondering where the Hecks
retro he's got his camera off uh you are
correct the camera is off I have a
really bad eye infection unfortunately
really bad eye infection and my eye is
just ridiculously swollen I mean I'd
show you guys I don't I don't really
care but I just don't want to uh I don't
want to subject you to that having to
stare because then I have to answer
questions all night what happened to
Retro's eye Retro's eye looks funny
what's wrong with his eye
it looks it looks it looks pretty bad
dude
my wife looked legit afraid I don't know
if Mrs raconteur is still here in the
chat she did I don't care what she says
like she you know in sickness and in
health right
right she was she was feeling it in that
moment when she saw my eye
she she was feeling the the in sickness
and in health line I know she was
alright so we're looking forward to
Dalian Keys which I've heard is actually
a
not the easiest of quests
oh there's one right there
okay let's see can we
well goodness this is like Harry and uh
see does that work
I don't know where it might lead me oh I
just need to follow it okay
whoa slow down oh my goodness where'd he
go
wait is he gone wait what did I do wrong
what did I do wrong did I just lose him
got into a fight with peeves
down
like down on the ground on the floor or
did he just keep going
dude it completely for real you're
already at your destination
where did he go
look for the cabinet
oh so don't even like I'm not supposed
to follow it all the way somewhere
handy resource indeed your field guys
okay there it is oh dude he was already
gone
he was just this key in there okay slap
oh you slapped the key okay interesting
all right so let's see
all right don't tell me Chad don't tell
me I'm trying to
pay my controller's not doing anything
[Music]
touchpad
oh is it like a timing thing do I
literally have to wait till
right when he starts to go by
oh like that
hey griffindor all right one house token
gotcha okay there we go
infer in for now uh Avalanche has said
they will stream again yes yes
uh it was supposed to be the last it was
invaluable she changed her dialogue oh
you a great tent
yo that's so cool hey here's something
you all you Gamers who beat it in two
days if you haven't done this yet here's
something you could try
they're gonna be like oh I already did
that I already did that too man I did
that
um
if you haven't went back and talked to
all the professors
make sure you go back and talk to all of
them and also make sure you get
alohomora to unlock most of them have a
private study
and it
there are some really cool stories that
come out of it as a result of that
and then a lot of times when you go in
their private study you're gonna find a
note that it may be something related to
the story that you learned or it may be
something slightly different but really
cool just like extra layers on the
character details
that I think has been a lot of fun
all right so now we gotta somebody said
how many more 50 more to go all right
settle in
settle in chat
uh yeah house I've I've been doing some
twitch streams as well so make sure you
guys are following over there too if if
you don't already it's just the same
name
retro raconteur we've been doing like I
because of the drops
we've been doing some Twitch streaming
as well so the original plan
was we're gonna do like Focus really
hard on all the YouTube streams for all
of the launch of Hogwarts Legacy like
you know this first
two weeks to a month kind of that first
while the game's still new and
everything that period
and then maybe look at kind of branching
out to twitch but whenever they
announce those drops I really just
wanted to do it because it's a really
great Community thing and we've brought
in a lot of new people over there as a
result of it so
yeah my hope is to be doing uh we may
actually do a twitch stream tomorrow
we'll see we'll see I'm kind of waiting
to see how my eye does tomorrow I got
some drops for it I had to pick up
prescription drops were you able to
able to wait I have to come back to
every time surely not surely it's just a
one-time thing I'm actually much to
guess it's a daily and key into its lock
brilliant what did you find in the
cabinet curious token of some sort
of token I better unlocks our house
chest I call them house chests I've seen
the one in our common room and her bear
are also in the other common rooms keep
an eye out
oh yeah I did find that I do hope you
continue on for so much effort the prize
must be something Grand
see this through and fight could see if
she has any other dialogue Keys work
again when you spot or hear a flag okay
yep you've got to follow it back to its
cabinet inserting it in the lock is the
tricky part I hope you follow some if
you open a cabinet I'd love to know what
you find if anything
hmm alrighty then all right so I can't
do anything with that big chest in the
common room right until I get all of
them is that what she was saying
I was kind of reading Chad at the same
time
uh gaming Arc I have not tried it on PC
I've heard some some people are having
performance issues and then some people
are saying what you said that it sounds
great or that it looks great I know Nico
had just a few problems but
and then L one's playing on PC as well I
think they're both having a good time
with it I do I do plan to try it out on
PC at some point yeah
I also want to hear any uh any steam
deck players out there
anybody tried it on Steam deck
curious how it runs there okay thank you
uh Evo Senpai and gaming Arc appreciate
it yeah so I don't need to go back to
the common room or anything
and then um
so there was another question somebody
was hey you might as well go ahead and
unlock this while we're here
FPS drops but it's worth it
little Pro tip on these you guys
at the beginning just immediately test
out all the directions without rotating
at all and a lot of times you will get
one to start spinning
without doing anything else
oh my goodness what do we have here
a demi guys mine now Demi guys
all right this was in my YouTube video
today guys if you haven't watched this
one yet whenever you're doing the hunt
for the Demi guys
they do not light up on revelio in the
daytime which makes sense because you
can only collect them in the daytime
but sometimes at Hogwarts it gets kind
of difficult to tell whether it's night
or day
so make sure when you're hunting these
guys down which now I'm curious I'm
going to turn on the mini map actually
since we're doing collecting tonight I
might just keep the minimap on for
tonight's stream
all right let's go ahead and turn it on
I want to see if they show up on here
no they do not okay now let's take it
let's take it to night time oh wait he
just said mine now he usually only says
that when he yeah
let's go ahead and take it tonight
the evening hours
all right
runs great on Steam deck oh that's
awesome to hear
I've been thinking about getting one
not for a while but
but that is good to hear
all right see now okay it still doesn't
show up on the mini map but when you do
revelio
there it is see even from back here
do a little revelio but if it was still
daytime I wouldn't be able to see him
all right let's check our status with
Gladwin out I'm curious to see how many
more we need
we got Dylan in the house as well what's
up Dylan
and then Professor Baxter Professor
Baxter how's it going appreciate all the
comments on the videos Professor Baxter
always see you there in the comments
appreciate you taking the time
okay so where is our boy Gladwin
The Man Behind the moons okay so we did
five so now we got six all right so we
still need seven more moons
what I do like is that the map it
you can easily see where you still need
to find millennials
honestly I think the easiest ones are
not in Hogwarts they're the ones out in
the little hamlets those areas
we're gonna have to go back and look at
uh those comments Benjamin made you guys
we're here I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
go and look at those Secrets try to look
into those all right so right now guys
we're on the The Daily in Keys Quest
we're gonna try to complete that one
here
huh
yeah
which I hear it is fairly lengthy we've
got 16 more to go
oh yeah we just came from here
is she actually
I think it's gonna make it's gonna make
us go back to the common room
or maybe there's one in the common room
well protero was talking about seeing
the entrance to Gryffindor here you go
here you go
get to see it right here
I guess she just wanted me to go over
and verify
the chest is here this must be my house
chest seems I'll need to find more house
tokens if I'm to open them okay so you
just have to do it for the first time by
the look of it yep quite a few indeed
all right now Lead Me
no path available for Open West
objectives what
what
maybe I need to mark it again
what season uh we're in Spring
yeah we're at what I think is the last
one
foreign
oh my gosh you can't Mark and find them
no
[Music]
all right that might that's why pale
writers comment about 16 There are 16
keys to be honest on my second character
I already have over half of them okay so
I guess if you just know
you're a wizard oh my gosh chat all
right well this this is a good one to do
for stream
because I got you guys I got you now see
this is the kind of thing like bring on
the back seating like you can help me
with this
all right where where should I go look
first and Dylan with the five gifteds
Dylan thanks so much man hope you're
having a blast with with Hogwarts Legacy
we got a kashiki lawn key Stefan
Stefan politis guwop wow names I have
never seen in stream before just got
five gifteds congratulations guys make
sure you think Dylan there for the
gifted membership uh you can enjoy the
Emoji now that we have here in the
Stream some fun uh Wizarding World
related any high top anywhere and
everywhere wait are there only 16 though
so there's only 16 or can I can I find a
bunch of them
astronomy Wing near defense what I'm
hearing is I just need to wander is what
what I'm hearing
I just need to wander around what about
uh our pal rivello
velio help out much
all right I also wish the little marker
would go off for Gladwin Gladwin I don't
want you anymore dude
where are you
man behind the moons let's see if I Mark
him and then unmark him if it will turn
it off
and then the daily and keys we got one
out of 16.
okay yeah now it goes away I don't know
why the markers do that sometimes
revelio will show you the key in the
cabinet yeah I've seen a bunch of the
cabinets
revelio
but the keys themselves yeah
need alohomora okay yeah I have I have
the basic alohomora is that enough
actually I have level two
oh is there a there must be a field
guide page in here that I did not get
chest as well let's go ahead and unlock
it
the keys are always close to the cabinet
ah good to know
hello
faculty tower has two okay
what about kitchens am I wasting my time
oh I did miss a field guy page in here
boom
the kitchen tables
oh another one
miss two in here
oh we're gonna be leveling up like crazy
tonight
they're never far away from the cabinet
okay good to know good to know keys are
usually in your cabinets both cabinets
and keys can be revealed by revelio but
you got to be close keys are pretty
small hard to spot you'll hear it okay
good to know
oh Alicia that that's cool
revelio
all right so looks like nothing in the
kitchens
in terms of the key but you guys are
saying the faculty Tower
all right so let's actually let's
actually do a flu Flame
to get to that side
all right so the faculty side let's see
here
that's actually over there close to to
Gladwin right
what's up
let's start we'll start with the
astronomy Tower
travel there
taught you how to lock pick
okay here's another one chat what does
it mean
I've noticed this a lot and I'm almost
positive it means something when you
fast travel to an area
and you first
arrive you feel like the tiniest of
vibrations in the center of the
controller
I've always said that travel for a while
I thought it meant Field Guide page oh
that's the one I already got right there
okay so that one's done
I thought it meant Field Guide page but
now it keeps happening
so I'm like there is something else
that this means
one by the grand stairs
just where I was
all right that's room of requirement
rebelio
oh
revelio
how do you get into the kitchen uh so
for me protero there was a mission that
took me there and then once I did it
now it seems like it's it stayed open
yeah I don't know if there's another way
to unlock it or not
dude I'm following this is this is
exactly the same path I just followed
chat
actually the same path I just followed
the Goblins had no Prospect of success
oh the Bloody Baron dude I don't think
I've ever seen the Bloody Baron
oh yeah I have seen him I just didn't
recognize him immediately yeah yeah I've
seen this guy
I'm so used to how he looks in the uh
in the old games
you're Hufflepuff though right Alicia I
wonder if hufflepuffs
I had to do it on a quest
okay wait
revelio
I feel like there's one near this area
oh my gosh
you guys are taking me all over the
place
people keep keep people keep throwing
out different uh
different ideas
well it is way too quiet right here all
right chat here we go here's one right
here
here's one right here revelio
all right so let's listen ooh is this it
over here maybe
there you are
all right go to that
does it just go straight there or do I
have to like lead it to it okay good it
goes straight there perfect
I wonder if you could like
I'm gonna try this
see if we could like freeze it
does this make you go slower
oh come on
there we go
all right
two down
you go to the kitchen says yeah I was
thinking you had to pass a certain point
in the story before it would let you
want you to go find the one all the way
in points your Coast no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no they're all in
Hogwarts pretty sure of that
I am pretty sure of that all right
that's two down
and then I saw somebody say something
about
other houses get access to it when it
hits Winter ah good to know Nico there
you go
this was a cool little puzzle right here
took me way longer than it should have I
was
you guys are having trouble with this
one there's the code right there
here's how I was trying to solve it I
thought
this is the first one that I looked at
and I thought like it was drawing a
circle around where that line crosses
the triangle so I thought this one was
one because it it had like one intersect
point
I thought this one was two because it
has two intersect points I thought this
one was three because it had three and
then I thought that one was four
but nope I was making it way too
difficult
all right Transfiguration flu Flame
Rebellion
we'll try that one next
oh I just love the music
I love the music
dude look at that little owl just
chilling up there
you thought the same thing for tarot
right I'm like I'm just making it way
too hard I guess
there's actually a key right here
telling me how to do it on the ground
all right see you right there chat just
straight down with the red one
so then that means all I have to do is
figure out this one
same here pale Ryder
oh man just example of me overthinking
Sleek sorcerer hat anything else in here
no but we are getting the little chime
which means we are close to
you're very close
wait did I just I think I just heard the
key yeah there you are
all right you want me to actually walk
up and get you to go
all right there go to your
go to the lock
all right let's try another one okay
oh he's right on there though oh I
should have
foreign
it's a pretty fun one pretty fun one
all right so we knocked that out what
level oh what am I 33 32 almost 33
all right let's go down here I hired
somebody's there was someone earlier who
said there's
at least one in the dungeon
ortero if you're still here what what
house did you say you are
Gryffindor right or you said you're not
a Gryffindor
have you ever heard you say it but in my
mind
green is such a big part of your color
scheme for everything all your
your online presence I'm I'm just like
assuming you're Slytherin in my head
Ravenclaw okay nice nice nice
I just like imagine you as a Slytherin
because of all the green
revelio
oh okay
foreign there is definitely a field
guide page
oh it's got to be in here all right we
do have the level two so that's good
the keys sound like Hey listen oh see
this one same thing just go to the right
there it is right there
love the game why is nobody sleeping at
night
I know that'd be a fun thing to patch in
right if you actually saw the
other students
and you're like sneaking around and
they're just still resting laying in
their beds at night oh
there you are wait really
I have to be facing I was facing a
different way I couldn't believe that it
didn't detect it
[Music]
yeah Megan we did that the other night
on I think we were streaming over on
Twitch when we found that yeah
that's a pretty fun one
detention chamber this chamber allegedly
served as the school's preferred
location for punishing students the
physical torture is no longer utilized
during detention the aura of such
horrific practices lingers
okay
yeah I agree Baxter the sound design is
so good oh I didn't even recognize see
you over there
well let me just go right out
for Tara even after watching a few
videos I have no idea how the locker
mini game works
I'll I'll try to explain it next time we
uh next time we have one
because I was the exact same way we got
to play the game early and it was pretty
much unanimous all of us were like eh
don't know about this lock picking game
and so I don't know if they actually
tweaked something behind the scenes
based on our feedback or if it was just
one of those things where we're where
they're like no we're gonna stick to it
and we think once you guys get in your
hands it'll make more sense
but for me it's like like now that I've
gotten a chance to play it you guys
seeing these moving staircases do not
excuse tardiness I love it
this one says something about
not all beasts make great pets that was
for Hagrid
how about this one here
no magic in the corridors
uh same same one for moving staircases
do not excuse tardiness
uh brooms belong on the pitch dude these
look a little bit like umridges remember
when she had her rules posted all the
new rules she was adding obviously this
is well before her time but cauldron's
clean keep cauldrons clean
something concoctions
between between concoctions
it's very easy on PC Ellen says yeah it
for sure gets easier even on Console the
more you do them absolutely
movie staircases do not equal tardiness
that one's the best I like that a lot
that's really good all right looks like
we've done everything in this room
dude that sounded like a basilisk right
there not even gonna lie
all right we already checked that one
out and this is the one that just hold
on I think this might lead
I think this might lead to the map room
which I don't even know what's gonna be
oh no not the not the map room
setup
I've never been in here
I'm going to ask her this time you said
that 40 years ago
did you see that she did me my dear
amount of shoulders I'm afraid it was I
that Drew her gaze
oh my goodness
you should if you're trying to work up
the courage to talk to this lady
my hand didn't die
this is too good
I did it I asked I'm forgetting why'd
you leave your head though bro
why'd you leave your head dude
and they just leave the head
oh my goodness what is this room
maybe the field guide page over here
will tell us a little bit more Rebellion
let's see
headless hunt tapestry this tapestry
depicts The Headless hunt a group of
headless ghosts organized by Sir Patrick
Delaney podmore to play various headless
games they are notorious for refusing to
admit Gryffindor House ghost Sir
Nicholas to Mimsy porpington to their
ranks as he is not entirely headless
a technicality for our poor boy Sir
Nicholas
technicality
all he wants is to be part of the
Headless hunt
I know without his head
I wonder if I can go over and just like
talk like can I oh we I probably can't
interact with the ghost can I
can I pick can I take you over to to
your body
but if you could destroy the table and
then the head just Falls
oh it's the death day party room yeah
oh wait I'm hearing another one oh
there's one on the other side of the
room too see I keep making the mistake a
lot of times I'll find one and just
assume that's it
yep there you go you called it death day
party room this Gloomy spacious chamber
in the lower dungeons of Hogwarts is
perfect for occasional death day party
celebrated here by the castle ghosts
most Mortals will want to avoid such
festivities as the Food Service
frequently rotting so the ghost can
detect its aroma
well I'm glad we came down here no
dadelian keys but hey two more Field
Guide pages
uh where's that at hold on Jake if you
watch me exit here you'll probably be
able to see so yeah Slytherin dungeon is
where I'm at right now
and then when we come out uh we're kind
of like right here and it has this gate
that automatically
closes
and automatically opens as I walk by
dude this looks like
hold up
this looks like an entrance right here
like that could be a secret entrance
oh man
that does too
check by the dragon statue oh wait
they're leaving now
oh she's leaving too
wait wait wait wait wait did the dude
get his head back
I'm so curious now
watch him just be still in here by
himself
oh he got his head he's gone
they left
that is so cool
uh let's see where are you talking about
Kathy the dragon statue
somewhere near where I'm at right now
there's a staircase where I thought
there was an entrance oh is that
and I guess you can't get back in here
yeah you're right
foreign
all good all good we're just uh having a
relaxing stream tonight
so not really doing anything Story
related just going around trying to
knock out some side quests as we work
toward our 100 right now we're doing the
daily and keys Quest but really as part
of that we're just exploring Hogwarts
yeah I thought you could get back in
there count Grizzly I thought so
I had to try
okay
and then Kathy was saying let me see I
don't see another comment from Kathy
about the dragon statue okay that's how
we came down but let's check this side
first
so you guys I now you all are truly
going to get to see all these months
that you all been watching me stream and
I've been telling you guys like hey I'm
bad with directions
you're gonna get to see it now yeah
there you go that's where you can get
into the scriptorium right there and so
there's the Slytherin common room that's
where you would get in right there
oh we got a statue up here
revelio
oh I just walked past it the Dragon one
all right
let's go back
see the joys of stream delay
there's always a little bit of a delay
no matter what I do always a little bit
of a delay
so bad wow Mrs raconteur chiming in
chiming in on the direction comment
don't lie you you enjoy it you like
being the one who
who controls our path whenever we travel
should be near the stairs okay
you you honestly do you love it
I mean I see the that's not a dragon
statue though
it's a snake statue
she says get good
oh basically basically
oh this right here
I mean I know you can like interact with
them and do that but
doesn't look like there's anything else
oh it's a three-headed dragon okay
big statue all right
so not not where I'm at right now though
right Kathy
let's go ahead and check out
revelio
make sure okay nothing here
all right
okay gotcha gotcha
all right I want to go check this way
so you got this really awesome statue
right here
open sesame
all right somebody said Transfiguration
so we need to go do
peeves get out of here dude
that's the thing I've seen him do more
than any is slide down that right there
all right let's just yeah we'll just
travel to it
let's see
Transfiguration
Courtyard flu flame head through the
doors behind you up the stairs left to
the rhinoceros skeleton
those are the kinds of directions I need
right there
Rebellion here's another dragon statue
as long as I don't get sidetracked
Moon Lily I have to make sure I don't
get sidetracked
all right head to the doors behind you
all right all right
oh yeah I think I know about the big
Rhino you're talking about
below the history of magic classroom
okay there's the Rhino over there oh my
goodness peeves
he gets around quick
yeah there's a key right there
revelio
all right the problem is I don't know
where this one goes
all right come on go
lead the way
up the stairs
oh I see it I see it still yeah there we
go
[Music]
yeah you gotta gotta be very detailed
with me I appreciate it
all right so there's one more down
Rebellion
oh let's see if I haven't been in
Professor heckett's private yet private
study
I'm telling you guys if you haven't went
into the private studies yet
whoa didn't mean to do that oh wait okay
portero was saying how does this work
all right so first thing for tarot just
move focus on moving one stick at a time
so if you go up down left right with the
left stick and you don't get any
spinning then just pick a direction
doesn't matter which one so I'm just
gonna go up and I'm only moving left
analog stick right now so I'm going to
start all right so there we go so see
that one starts spinning I have to keep
holding the left stick though see if I
like if I move it too much then it's
gonna it's gonna mess up so I have to
keep it in just the right spot and now I
need to test out the right one too so
the right one I'm gonna start turning it
and it will start spinning in the center
right there and then I just hold both of
them there you go
there you go
takes like five tries oh really to get
the uh
all right I'm telling you guys if you
can
okay so let's read this note here
dear Dinah
so this is letter two Professor heckett
here dine as her first name I know
you're as disappointed as any regarding
the cancellation of this year's
quidditch season despite my repeated
efforts I cannot seem to convince the
Headmaster
to reverse his decision even if it were
for a shorter period of time might I
impose upon you to reach out to him it
occurred to me that perhaps hearing from
someone from his school years someone
alongside whom he may have once cheered
for a match or two
well I thought it could possibly sway
him yours gratefully Chio or Chayo
c-h-i-y-o
and then also a chest here I want to
make sure that I'm not full on my gear
see what are we at oh we're at 19 okay
we're good
we're very good right now so let's go
ahead and open this unidentified
which I'm pretty sure if you save any
unidentifieds until you hit max level
I think they will all
level three lock right there revelio
I think they will
break down at your max level oh two
level three locks here in Professor
heckett's area
all right so see another spot we have to
remember to come back later
once we've gotten all the moons for our
boy Gladwin
which that might be something we can
tackle here after we
do this to Dalian Keys Quest
by the way I don't I don't want to give
away too much of the story stuff since
we're focusing on side quests tonight
but my goodness
that last scene with the let's just say
involving the professors oh my goodness
that was so epic
that was so epic I loved it revelio
oh yeah somebody was talking about a
dragon maybe it's this
oh no that's not a dragon
so if you're just tuning in chat we are
hunting for dedalian keys that
is our goal tonight the daily and keys
it was it was so good
I like I was like cheer actively
cheering at that part
just shouting at my TV let's go
the same way I get hyped like when we
watch trailers and stuff guys all this
leading up to this game
that's that's literally how I am when
I'm playing the game too
I saw somebody ask earlier I don't know
if they're still here if we're gonna do
more playthroughs and have them as Let's
Plays absolutely yeah
I mean I plan to do
for sure two playthroughs most likely
three probably many many more
but then a lot of this like exploration
stuff too is gonna be fun
can you get back into the Headmaster
study
you can right
why is the floor smoking so that area is
the uh
it has a specific name it's a room that
like smells really bad or something
oh you can't get back in there good I
was hoping so all right wait is that
what is that circular
please
please all right somebody was saying
there's some in the Great Hall let's do
the Great Hall
we'll just start in the viaduct
Courtyard oh hey good timing there
good timing SK
all right should I look around out here
probably just go on in right
[Music]
anything over here
look at this dude
shiny mooncalf let's go
oh Zenobia remembers that I found her
gobstones oh wait yeah we were here
earlier and I just stopped
I didn't go all the way through
oh is that one over there oh no that
sucks
oh there's one
nice good call good call
where are you going
oh I'm watching you this way okay
ah there we go nice
excellent excellent
spoiler free chat uh relatively dreaming
relatively yeah I've beaten the game the
main story so we're just kind of going
through and
doing some side quest stuff tonight
yes Professor Baxter what a great move
to include
shiny creatures all right let's see if
it's is it keeping track of this for me
guys I feel like we've gotten I don't
know four five okay perfect all right so
11 more to go
uh that are around Hogwarts all right
are there any outside you guys any that
I need to look for
are they all inside the main part of the
castle
let's see somebody was saying grand
staircase
here's what we could do we could start
yeah let's just start right here or
actually we could just walk out there
and do that
no sense in fast traveling to that oh
wait what is this one have I not
unlocked this
alohomora Aloha Mora
oh there it is
clock tower has two okay
first yeah cap
all right Clock Tower let's see what is
the fastest way
what is the closest Blue Flame
then check gray and staircase oh here's
one right here all right
I was gonna say somebody said grand
staircase
all right little key where are you
oh I heard it
I heard it
above me or below
oh is it way up there no way
heard it again
Rebellion
oh no where did it go
oh it's all the way up there okay
and here we gotta run all the way back
down
there you are
be gone
let's see if I can beat the key to the
bottom
probably not right
oh wait I think this was it right
nope
wrong spot wrong way wrong way
here it is
come on
the anticipation
all right perfect okay now let me scroll
back up and look here
oh somebody said there's two in the
Great Hall all right let me go back
and then clock tower has two as well
okay
all right so let's try to find the other
one in the Great Hall revelio
and then we'll do Clock Tower
or Moon Lily saying Central Hall flu
flame down the stairs and right at the
fountain oh a key okay I like those
directions so
all right
oh wait I just saw now that's another
lock
Aloha might as well
might as well don't mind if I do
what do we have here
Demi guys oh Jimmy guys all right we
might as well
take it tonight revelio
let's take it to night time just so we
can grab this Demi guy okay this is good
though that we're we're finding demigay
statues while we're searching for them
guys
so knocking out two things that I wanted
to do at the same time perfect
all right somebody was saying there's
two in the Great Hall I'm not seeing a
am I missing something
I'm not seeing a second one here in the
Great Hall
so we got we got that one right there
maybe I need to keep going oh upstairs
oh there's two what
all right apparently there's another one
nearby somewhere
I don't know where
I don't know where chat
oh wait maybe something over here
Rebellion
come on early
revelio
shh Craig don't tell don't tell people
that
you pick keep it keep it quiet
I still like I haven't I haven't looked
in into that enough
like I don't know what people are I I
can't believe they that would that's
actually how
it happens
I need to read more into that though
I think everybody knows all right
probably so
like I still haven't finished all my
quests though so I don't know maybe I
get to go somewhere cool too
Rebellion
maybe I get to go somewhere cool all
right what am I missing guys it should
be there me store was saying maybe I
already got that one do you know where
the uh case for it is like the the lock
where you take it to
because if we if we could find that then
I could see if I had it or not
if I had the key in the lock
outside the Great Hall doors okay
revelio
oh the suits of armor are fighting don't
remember one in the Great Hall yeah I
got one in there Jack I definitely got
one
yeah I don't think there's another one
guys or I already got it one of the two
all right moonly let's go to
Moon Lily says
Central Hall flu flame down the stairs
then right at the fountain
alright so
where is the central Hall flu Flame
foreign
[Music]
where is the central Hall flu Flame
there it is
all right
and then moonly said down the stairs
then right at the fountain
a key by the entrance to the greenhouse
oh okay nice
all right here is
Rebellion yep I heard it
I heard the little key gotcha
yo shout out to moonly again
with the incredibly specific directions
and here we go right
Focus your energy
that's it the anticipation
gets me every time
the anticipation
all right and then somebody else was
saying two in the clock tower area I do
remember seeing those
do you remember seeing those
like the uh
the chest or whatever you call it where
you unlock
right jack great directions
moon cavalish is holding a DeLeon key
not click bait oh goodness
all right so
chug's working on 100 as well really
tough pages in The Faculty Tower
behind a fireplace oh I got I did get
one behind a fireplace but I think it
was in the library
I think it was in the library
I'll have to remember that
okay hold on though I want to do these
uh
here's the Clock Tower
I want to do the clock tower one next
see that's probably going to be South
wing
Hospital Wing Hogwarts South exit
Clock Tower Courtyard
oh here's faculty Tower a lot of people
were saying faculty Tower too
let me go check out the faculty tawa
and also near the prefect bathroom
what up Gladwin
can I just go in here now and roam free
alohomora
Wow first try oh my God first try in
both directions
let's go
[Music]
what should we unlock here
oh another note
Eleazar you were right about the bow
truffles I owe you a cannot Miriam
oh my goodness oh what a sweet letter
a short but very sweet letter hello
homura
oh okay we got that one
and
come on come on there you are
oh I messed up the red one though
is one in the clock tower too okay
perfect
all right we just got to keep an eye on
our loot to make sure we don't max out
here
any more Demi guy statues in here
oh wait that might be one right
oh no that's another lock I guess
dude I love this I've seen two of these
now these little
self-writing quills
Enchanted quills okay wait so there's
nothing in this room I know there's
another room that it leads to but
okay well
oh there we go guys there's another one
all right I feel like
I feel like it's gonna be up the stairs
marvelous simply marvelous
marvelous isn't it
there we go
oh wait you're going to a different one
maybe nope nope nope back down back down
I scrub his shoulders
you're watching that scene right now
you're watching the movies
and leave him so dude scrope is just
adorable by the way
phineas's house
poor guy and
I wonder if we can find out what
happened to his ear
s
Nick's complaining that that his doesn't
get dusted
no way to dwell
see this is the kind of stuff I love
dude by the black family sir are you
saying that to annoy me no padding
service yes I see your point choose your
battles I say I shall be polished
another day
fretting
oh my goodness
okay oh we actually have one of these
that we haven't opened yet
well let us do this shall we
all right so let's see we got five in
the spider
oh let's see so wait
okay
it's gonna be zero so I was like hold on
is this your question Demi guys and then
we got three plus the grab horn which is
two that's five okay so we need a nine
which is
that thing
yep you
I know I feel bad for him too having to
uh put up with Phineas
ravelio
collection updated and moving portraits
okay is that it or is there something
else you're supposed to do in here
oh we can we not go down because I
definitely saw more stuff below
probably shouldn't just jump down there
should we
revelio
hey here's another one
see I'm hesitant to how many of these I
should unlock right now
I mean what is in there another note
and loot doesn't look like what we're
after so
let's see Moon Lily says on the highest
floor of the faculty Tower okay we'll
find a corridor of portraits and it
links to the clock tower okay very cool
let's get all the way up there revelio
oh hold up though
can I hit you from right here
can I
go
oh no
wait maybe we can once we go up
maybe we can look down
no
I don't know how to hit that one
you can hit it from the stairs okay let
me go back
maybe like these stairs
oh come on maybe I should like aim for
above it
instead of aiming for
the railing like aim like right here
nope
oh come on
all right Josh
you gotta you have gotta help guide me
if I can hit it from the stairs
let it on fire but you can't pick it up
oh I'm about to blow your mind Milan in
the house
you can accio the page
kill it unless unless it's like on the
other side
but I think you should be able to accio
it oh the spiral ones I ran down oh from
like here so like kind of go up a little
bit
oh my gosh no way
no way couldn't bring them oh no that's
not gonna hit it
wait wait it's kind of back up right
here
oh oh oh okay
oh it's hitting the statue
Keys retro keys but there's just like
this little there's just this little
there's just a little Field Guide page
waiting to be discovered here
oh come on
I think Josh is just messing with me
don't lie Josh you're just mess with me
aren't you I can't actually hit it from
here
I cannot hit it from here
ah fine
we'll get it later
okay there's one right here
this is what we're actually looking for
different keys
all right so
I think I see the key right here
burning the whole school
stop it
go to the fireplace in Sharp's room
I think I remember which one's sharps
Alicia
oh my gosh oh that was a quick one
very quick one
you can get it from there from Sharp's
room okay
you guys just gotta guide me to Sharp's
room but now I want to see if uh
rebellio
okay let's check for anything else in
here
already done the puzzle that was a
really cool puzzle by the way
the gears on the clock
boom
managed to hit it but you can't find the
way around to pick it up oh and so you
can't use accio on it to pull it down to
you
did forget about feeding my animals
Dr sherbet I mean there's just there
there was a Wizarding World to be saved
the animals were fine they were doing
fine
were they a little hungry yes but they
were
they were making it they were making it
revelia
all right so we just got another one up
here
okay so we're looking for you guys are
saying Sharps room
alohomora
oh man s s King kxng I think it was just
for
I think it was just like a random loot
chest
I think
okay
Noreen what in the world I didn't even
know you were there
oh
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry Hospital Lane oh my goodness
tasmina mclagan
or so we assume age 13.
Cormac it remember Cormac guys
the patient stumbled in without a head
excuse me
after a head count of the dorms and
absolutely no assistance from the
Headmaster we concluded that the student
was most likely tasmina mclagan despite
the obvious communication challenges I
was able to discern that the poor girl
was suffering from Vanishing sickness I
recommended that she be sent to Saint
mungo's at once partly owing to the time
since nature of the diagnosis and partly
because nearly headless Nick was
floating around moaning on and on about
how very lucky she was
he was most distracting and if he
disrupts my dealings with future
headless students I shall have no choice
but to ask the Headmaster in order to be
oh dude nearly headless Nick causing
some problems
causing some problems
I'm told that the patient is recovering
and can be expected to return to the
castle soon of no particular
significance Nick now seems to be
avoiding me
one might assess that he's steeping
himself in a somewhat childish sulk wow
okay
anything besides the chest here
Scottish jumper attire
you caught a thestral and a unicorn
let's go guys I still haven't even seen
unicorns in this game
oh yeah speaking of that Ellen was
saying to check my uh collections page
see how many creatures
yep I still have two more to go
I'm assuming unicorn and Phoenix is what
I'm assuming
we just got grap horn because we got the
lord of the shore
yeah I haven't even seen unicorns
I haven't even seen them yet
oh wow only one spawns at a time
all right so hold up you guys were
saying I need to get into Sharp's office
okay
let's let's guide retro
the Sharp's office that project begins
now
is this it maybe no prefix bathroom okay
I think I've already done the
I think I've gotten everything in here
oh I need the third level spell okay
never mind
[Music]
oh yeah I see it through the wall right
there
yeah maybe I shouldn't keep trying to
hit it if uh somebody was saying they
hit it and now they can't get the field
guide page for it okay that's level
three
how do you unlock thestral mount
uh you should unlock it just by that was
sharp stream oh gotcha the one that was
locked
oh wait wait wait
oh that sounds right above me
all right
where is it I'm just gonna go and open
this
yeah sorry uh Tater exactly what
Slytherin reviews said there
after the quest where you rescue High
wing
oh interesting no one says it should
already be unlocked you have to go to
gear and equip it oh
even before you've unlocked mounts at
all
received your letter this morning and
I'm thrilled to hear that all is going
well for you in that side Hogwarts even
if natsai's been a little challenging of
late
I suppose it is only to be expected
since both of our daughters are how
should I put it strong-willed we miss
you at wagadu it is not the same without
you but we understand why you felt the
need to move on
I do not think that I could have
remained here myself under the
circumstances
how life does send us all down such
unpredictable paths one never truly
knows what awaits
not even though such as yourself who
have the sight but I am confident that
good things are ahead for you in natsai
at Hogwarts or wherever you may go I do
hope to hear from you again and I wish
you the best of luck in the meantime
your loyal friend Amalie Amelie
so this must be
Professor own eyes private study
I was thinking so yeah once you unlock
the flying mounts yeah yeah exactly
all right I'm hearing it It's gotta be
in here there we go
sketched inside the cover of this old
slightly worn set of serialized
Adventure novels is what looks like a
gazelle
perhaps the novels were a gift Professor
onai or her daughter natsai
just taking Nat's eyes Professor onai's
money right there all right
it's all good though nobody Minds
okay guys alright so did Alien keys back
to the dedalian Keys
oh wait didn't somebody say Clock Tower
and we were just there let's go back
or did I already was that the one did I
find the one in the Clock Tower
because there's a the clock tower it's
pretty
revelio pretty elaborate in here there's
a lot I bet I'm supposed to go up this
way
possibly over here
oh I'm not seeing anything pop up
top of the clock tower thank you Kathy
yep all right so
this way
revelia
wait this is where I already was the
hospital Wing off on another adventure
are we no no no no no no no
all right I'm at the top is it the one I
already got
it's like the second or third level Josh
says okay
let me go over here to this side
it is agreed Cindy agreed
which now that I've beaten the game I'm
just like I'm totally fine with that
oh okay there's
wait is that it down there I think I
need to get to the bottom
you already get this okay yeah I've
already been over here
at some point I've already been over
here
all right down we go
[Music]
oh my gosh
that's so elaborate
Rebellion okay there it is
now the key
the key is right there
Okay so we've got to get down
uh we'll see
over this oh wait there's another one
somebody said two in here
or no that's
that is the one okay then I thought is
there another one all the way at the
bottom no okay so it's that one
I've got to get it up the stairs
[Music]
all right there you are
let's see if it just automatically goes
up there now
are you in there
yes all right they gotta be on my toes
that last one went quick
come on come on come on
Oh I thought that was it there we go
all right apparently there's a whole
puzzle with the clock tower yes it's
pretty cool Dr sherbet I did that one
last night
yeah involving these symbols right here
and then you have to do something like
a wrestler momentum like that right
there
and then it will only open the door
while it stays Frozen on there it's
pretty cool
so it opens up a lot of these door like
the door at the very bottom
it opens from that
all right let's go back down
I might check my status again because I
feel like I feel like we're past the
halfway point for sure
if you guys are just tuning in thank you
for dropping by and hanging out on this
what is it a Tuesday evening Valentine's
Day
hope everybody's having a good day no
cam tonight I've had unfortunately been
suffering from a
pretty nasty eye infection so just
didn't feel like having the big lights
and the camera on tonight
but we are still here having a good time
hanging out playing Hogwarts Legacy we
have beaten the story
so we're not really talking story
spoilers here but we are going around
and doing side quests right now and so
I'm currently trying to do the the daily
and keys Quest
and
let's just go ahead and get a check and
see where I'm at
let's just get a check okay quests
we are at 10 of 16. all right not bad
not bad six more to go
don't forget to like And subscribe says
Dr sherbet hey thank you Dr Sherman
appreciate it guys uh likes do help out
the video and of course subscribers also
help tremendously as well we're getting
very close closing in on 50K Subs
closing in on 50K so if you're here and
you're watching and you're not
subscribed
uh consider it if you're having a good
time then you'll be able to see anytime
we're live there's a little icon that
shows up on the channel there you go A2
right there sometimes all you gotta do
is ask Dr sherbet lady fortune and
Gregory thank you both appreciate it
Alicia imagine not being a retro sub
oh my all right here we go Moon Lily has
been steering us exactly in the right
direction
the whole time we've got six more to go
Great Hall area Viaduct
Courtyard boom that's where we're going
up the stairs right through the big
doors into the entrance Hawk
oh okay
I want to say we didn't we get this one
hold on hold on though hold on
Moon Lily has not steered us wrong yet
and moonly has been watching most
everything we've been doing so
I trust that I'm just misremembering
here
all right so go into the stairs to the
Courtyard to the big doors into the
entrance hall cabin is on your left yeah
this one okay yeah we got I think that
was like one of the first ones you might
not have been here when we did that one
got that one I did not do the library mu
store a good call and then uh let's see
somebody else Josh said there's a key
right at the top of the stairs by the
potions classroom the key will go down
the stairs into the room you go into
when you leave the map room
missed that one hey all good Moon Lily
no worries no worries all right so then
I will just go secret room and I'll just
go to the map chamber and leave from
there
you can hear the last page in the South
Wing but you can't find it oh that'd be
driving me crazy
how nice to see you all right so let's
just exit
the map chamber
revelio
you sure there's not anything here
okay top of the stairs by the potions
classroom the key will go down the
stairs
oh I think I saw it Oh I saw something
up there oh we gotta whoa we got a lot
here guys
I guess I've never been here
all right we've got a lot in this area
there's a field guide page
revelio
all right so we got a lock here level
one lock oh and one of the frogs okay
there it is right there
okay that's probably gonna take us
all right so now we gotta find the key
that one right there is that another one
and then is that another one
I mean no that's something else
toad statues lead you to loot yeah oh
there's the key I see it
go
go little one go
rebelio
oh oh wait wait wait oh there's another
key
all right all right all right all right
hold up we'll find that when we go back
apparently I've not explored this area
thoroughly at all
right so we're gonna do this one first
all right this is nice guys we're only
gonna have four left after we do these
two
so we'll get these two down here and
then we'll have four to go
[Music]
that's the dragons dragon statue
you I thought so Kathy I was about to
call it out
I was about to say I think that's the
statue
all right so let's go ahead and do this
lock right here alohomora
the frogs the loot they lead you to like
that's usually a pretty short and
short and sweet detour
you finish these yeah this one gives you
something the coolest robes in the game
so revelio
hadn't knocked it out yet thought I
might as well
as we work toward a hundred percent all
right
Field Guide page how about it
all right and can we exit right here
no Okay so
go
revelio
okay wait a second here
dude they should have totally had like a
jump scare moment right there like when
you grab that
I feel like the statue should have just
I don't know peeves or something bursts
out
oh that would be so funny
legendary chest if I go all the way on
this oh nice okay but before I do that
I'm gonna make sure that we're not full
on gear
because if we are
okay 27 we're still good we're still
good
should have roared dude could you
imagine it would have been so funny
oh man well this
oh this is super interesting like come
on now that doesn't I feel like that's
gonna lead somewhere
uh
oh no I can't remember which frog I
can't remember which frog we arrived in
I chose wrong
I think I got The Field Guide page yeah
yeah I think I got the field guy page oh
here we go nice
it's gonna be unidentified back item
top student cloak is pretty nice as well
still like the fnatic a bit more yeah
how's fanatic's pretty good Draco how's
it going welcome
welcome in revelio
oh yeah okay now we gotta go back down
there's another dedalian key down here
we need to find
after we travel back through the frogs
rocks frogs frogs and I think this is
the last one
there we go
okay perfect all right so we got that
detailing key that's over there now
we're gonna head this way
and there's another one okay let's make
sure we didn't get this
revelio
okay we did get that
[Music]
all right where are you going where are
you going
all right up the steps Maybe
yep
oh right there perfect not far at all
not far at all
got it
all right so we need four more I think
there are three keys oh I don't think
I've done that one yet Moon Lily I don't
think I have
okay before we go for the next set of
keys though
oh dude
oh no there's there's uh Field Guide
Pages everywhere
okay that one sounds like it's higher
but I also hear it way down here
you got that one it sounds like in my
headphones it sounds like it's through
there so wait maybe we need to do this
alohomora
oh come on
where is it
oh and there it is
I just did the potions one that she
mentioned oh nice nice
going off flu travel remember you're
going off memory with this moon really
okay that's ridiculously impressive
that's ridiculously impressive all right
feel bad page right here
important muggle artifact this
misunderstood artifact is supposedly
important to muggle Warfare but most of
wizard kind find the prospect of
wielding such a hefty weapon utterly
head scratching
foreign
I still hear another one and there's a
demi guys
what in the world
it's like somebody carving in here
oh this must be the Muggle studies
classroom
oh my goodness you guys
they just absolutely knocked it out of
the park when it comes to Hogwarts did
they not I mean
it is like a museum dude
a Hogwarts Museum that you can just
freely walk
it's so good all right well I'm gonna
change it tonight so we can get the Demi
guys
then I want to find this other field guy
page then I want to head to the library
and get three and then our big challenge
is gonna be figuring out what is the
last one
what is the last one that we don't have
yet
okay so it sounds like there's a
yeah definitely that direction
oh I bet it's behind this
which is level two a lot more okay
oh I missed it
come on all right there you are
Karthik welcome how's it going
enjoying the game so far
can I remember things well if you played
them over five times I know that's like
Dude that is so impressive that Moon
Lily remembers oh and we got one see
this is what I like right when you walk
in field guy page
Alchemy class dude this is all the other
classrooms we just had muggle studies
now Alchemy and Arcane subject offered
to older students on the rare occasion
when demand
suffices Alchemy focuses on the four
natural elements and the science of
transmutation
so cool dude just so freaking cool
look at this man
all right and that was it the chime has
stopped
basket red
after you get your first uh to me guys
you only need 18 more nice yeah I'm
about you know what I'm probably about
halfway on that too I've already got
level two so I'm on my way to level
three
all right so let's go to the library
let us go to the library Annex and
what do you think just straight into the
library right
just straight into the library
[Music]
what you have
sir are you all right you seem to be in
some distress
right
how can you be kidnapped when you're
right here
is that of course I'm right here I have
more than one frame do you only have one
home
it's my other frame
it's been I I'm getting those vibes
Alicia okay get those five
Ferdinand Octavius Pratt
I'm gonna say I'm not sure that's true
does it really happen or are you simply
being over dramatic oh we just call them
out
we called him out straight up oh
that's a story a cricket
her friends were moaning about me of all
the nerve then I heard a plot to enlist
a gang of good friends
to have meats
you put him in the place right there
half another place no I suppose one
could do worse I once knew a portrait
who ended up in the hog's head no one's
heard from him since right so back to
your frame ah yes
so I guess we're gonna get to decide
where his frame goes the way you guys
are talking
not to be at my post I know important
words sounds like I need to go back to
the car's uh
Tower when I get a little homura level
three
yeah there's so many areas I want to go
back to I I can't even remember all of
them because
I just keep thinking as I'm playing oh
man I don't have that unlocked yet I
need to unlock that
oh geez uh can you say anything I see
anything suppose you have any idea where
your stolen frame was taken can you see
anything from it
certainly can they brought me to a Rhine
of all places some crumbling atrocities
yeah this is uh this is performance mode
PS5 oh I do also recall seeing the
scene see the coast on the way
okay just who it is Astoria cricket and
what would you want with your frame
she's a
she's a troublemaker that's
a band of hoodlums discuss all sorts of
misdeeds right under my nose and then
resent me for overhearing them I can
only assume they took my friend in some
whoever did the voice acting on this had
a great time you can tell they had a
great time doing this voice what do you
mean you do important work for the
Headmaster let's just
just our new what's up
that's awesome
I need to check it actually on the PS5
because I don't think the in-game
counter for you is right I think I
played more than enough when I started
tonight I said 43 hours or something I
think I played a lot
me
no if you can then all right finally
dude he stopped talking
I oh see I don't like that it just
instantly marks that I don't want to go
after that Quest right now
no portrait in a pickle sorry we'll
we'll look at him too look at look look
at all these stinking side quests I have
to do man
which I'm not complaining I'm excited
about it
all right so apparently we got three did
Alien keys in here oh I see one
let's go
Percy
oh that's that's a good one that's
pretty spot on
Oh I thought it was about to go right
away
boom
all right so I think we're at
12.
no 11. I think we're at 11.
all right it's probably gonna be on the
next floor
I'm guessing
oh you know what I think one's over
oh maybe a Restricted Section
revelio
all right well I got one for sure oh
wait
that's just the flu flame though isn't
it
okay well not seeing one upstairs
yeah that's just a flu flame there
oh wait I just saw something though down
Rebellion
okay maybe we have to do
yeah here's here's the spot guys another
spot where in Cass glacias
go in here this little area
which I've already done that so
but right now if you're just tuning in
when you're on the hunt for the final
couple of the daily and keys
all right well restricted it is
should be one upstairs oh that's where I
just was we'll try that one again
I'm gonna check restricted first
Jack thinks there's only one in the
library
I don't know what that sound was
in the world
[Music]
it's not creepy at all
creepy at all
so we had I think Moon Lily said there
were three in the library
oh I'm seeing something oh that's a demi
guys right there
mine now dimmy guys
mine now
oh dude all these pages in here
all these books are moving man they're
moving
revelio
hey uh I don't know guys I'm not seeing
another one
I mean we're not done yet like we still
yeah we'll might as well go down there
because there's salute
this is like that very early mission you
do with Sebastian
all the way down here
wait what can I go back into the ancient
Magic Place
no way
I didn't know you could go back there
oh okay Josh said there's only one key
in the library no
all right now I just got to see what
happens I didn't know you could do this
again
I didn't know you could do this
what the heck
I've already beaten the story you could
still travel back
[Music]
it's like do the
the loot and stuff
that is crazy this one was really early
on now I just want to go in here and see
what happens
don't tell me I'm gonna have to beat it
though to get all the way out
oh I bet we do I bet we do chat
yeah I beat the story uh
early this morning late last night
Rebellion
ah I need to wake up that Rune over
there
okay wait I don't think I should go
through this again
I mean there clearly there's a reason
like
back here levioso
anyway maybe you're not supposed to come
back down here
I thought all you had to do was wake it
up was just blast it
L2 to free abler like okay he's having
trouble hitting it here
wait what no
excuse me
can you even do this again I know oh and
that's kind of why I'm like what happens
if I go through here again
what happens if I go through here okay
L2 to free aim you can go away now I get
it
oh I bet it's because like there are
certain things you miss
new with the Super Chat
hey thank you so much Noob Christy says
Hi also remember to stay hydrated well
hello Christy
hello to Christy as well is he able to
complete it that should be good
thank you for the Super Chat Noob really
appreciate it
good to hear from you as well Noob I
feel like I haven't seen you around as
much lately
I haven't seen you around
the question is how do we get over there
you think so Kathy you think so
yeah I'm gonna see if it'll just let me
go back
oh my goodness don't tell me there's a
oh no way right by the door
all right can we just leave let's see if
we can just leave
oh you can nice
maybe the uh press L2 to aim will go
away
oh this is so cool I didn't even know
you could do that chat so
that's pretty nice that you can go back
there
all right so the daily Keys though
detailing keys
did Alien keys that back all right
somebody was saying there's only one
here we got one somebody was saying they
thought there was one upstairs I checked
upstairs pretty thoroughly couldn't find
anything
although it was worth it coming in here
though because we found a demigas statue
as well that was nice
what I think is hilarious is that I was
using the game's lock-on mechanic
and apparently that one wasn't good
enough oh wait you know what I'm gonna
back out of this because I think we
might be full on gear let's see
oh one slot open you guys one slot open
all right so let me see here where you
guys were saying to go
hold on let me get the wow okay I'll
take it
I will take it
oh and I just saw your com sorry uh
count Grizzly just now saw your comment
left of the platform bridge will build
oh interesting so like if you
it'll uh if you hit the little button
with your spell it'll make it start
building over there if you're just kind
of lingering by
so not upstairs but below in the library
my bad
oh yeah yeah you're good Mew store
you're good everybody we're all just
everybody's just trying to help out
going based off our
our memories
all right so I'm pretty sure we're good
with the library so you guys were saying
divination and astronomy I definitely
got one of those
but I can't remember which one
and then let's just double check our
our total tally right now so for anybody
new dropping in okay we need three more
three more
Kathy said one in divination Tower Moon
Lily said astronomy Wing fast travel to
Transfiguration classroom flu Flame
okay I I definitely don't think we've
gotten the history of magic one
so let's shoot for that one first
astronomy Wing area
Transfiguration
classroom flu flame turn around and go
left through the doors into the North
Hall
key outside the history of magic
classroom
oh I knew Josh I knew that about the uh
Demi guys I did not realize it said it
for the keys too revelia
did not realize that could call hold on
I did not listen to what moonly said
though
uh turn around and go to the left
through the doors oh wait into the North
Hall hold on is this it no that's the
Transfiguration class
and I just heard something
hey North Hall's gonna be this way
all right we're here we're here
outside the history of magic classroom
all right oh Rebellion
I hear you
there it is
all right let's wait let's follow looks
promising
it's going up
this looks like the portrait from the
map
and where's the treasure
oh wait hold on we'll have to come back
down and do that I don't know what he's
talking about
okay not there
there it is
all right
two more
two more two more two more
but I want to see what he was talking
about when we went revelio
okay we were right
I need to open that too there's so many
things I need to do
right here he said something about
oh dude look at that
maybe this is a quest that I'm
supposed to be a quest that I've picked
up
oh accio
oh my gosh that's so awesome that was a
doorway hidden within the portrait
oh that's so cool
first time finding anything like that
such
authentic historians uniform
there are two at the library Annex
Central Hall wait isn't that where we
just Oh you mean maybe outside at Muse
tour outside
all right let me do this real quick
looks like there's quite a few things to
find behind here
Insight just stopping by to say hi well
hello my friend
appreciate you stopping by I hope you're
having a good
evening slash morning slash afternoon
whatever it may be for you
and if you're playing Hogwarts Legacy I
hope you are enjoying that as well
all right so we're gonna get incendio
gonna get a field guide page for you
oh and we got one of these to unlock
okay
all right so 10 plus the two or no two
plus the graph horn is four
so then we need the six which is
uh I think the six is the
man it's the lighting's kind of hard to
see the little salamander thing
all right and then we got three plus
four and then we need three
which is the Hydra
oh I missed it
open sesame
oh wait hold on I'm full on loot so I
don't need to open these yet I'm just
gonna have to break some stuff down
which I hate to do but I also don't want
to have to go sell right now
so we'll just do like I don't know
destroy that one the green
and that will destroy you another green
oh Christmas tree for the collection
nice revelio
all right so we're maxed out on gear
again
okay so wait you guys were saying though
that I can use the map to see so we
should be able to just look through the
map
or does it not say
I don't see where it says winged the key
is on there
oh no I didn't mean to do that darn it
does anyone know Taylor Swift I've heard
of her now I've I've heard of her
okay
I know I've already done a bunch of
Merlin trials but
yeah I'm not seeing that it's showing
it's showing astronomy tables
in the top right is does it actually
show you if you're missing uh keys
wrong okay yeah yeah I was like I knew
for sure it did Demi guys but not the
keys oh man all right so we're back to
square one back to square one we're
trying to figure it out
loved every minute of it Insight nice
yeah it's good stuff good stuff the way
it was definitely worth it
the weight was for sure worth it
all right so Josh said pretty sure we
got the library Annex now what I didn't
check though
I didn't check very much like outside
the library
and then somebody was saying divination
let's check divination one more time
we'll check divination
yeah there are a lot of distractions for
sure
Karthik doesn't want uh Karthik had to
leave didn't want the surprise of the
daily and keys getting spoiled I feel ya
I feel ya it's a pretty cool reward from
what I've seen
Trophy Room are near the trophy I think
I got the trophy room
oh wait actually I don't know if I got
this one guys
if there's one here in divination I
don't know if I got it
or no this is not divination is it this
is the arithmancy
area
which I don't think there's one back
here
no okay
astronomy Tower I think astronomy Towers
where we started
I think
maybe check the astronomy all right
we'll check that here in a second if uh
all right let's go all the way to the
top
is there one up here guys
is there any point going up here into
divination
SG I really hope if there are multiple
DLCs the first is a year with quidditch
the second is a try wizard tournament
with a certain guest also having to
compete similarly to how Harry was
chosen yeah there are so many good uh I
think potential ideas for DLC
which the way that I've seen
um
the way that it's selling there's one up
here oh let's go
I think DLC is highly highly likely are
you banned uh clearly not
not if you're seeing your name in chat
it's on her desk thank you for
protecting you guys are talking about
Demi guys now I already got the Demi
guys we're looking for uh the alien keys
daily in Keys
it's like node to daily key
all right back down we go
all right let's see somebody was saying
did you get central Hall may have missed
that one
hey I'm down to try whatever the grimly
how's it going because I think we only
need two more
we need two more detailian keys guys
I'm just kind of running through here
just doing a quick quick scan nothing
here okay
just doing a quick scan of the area
all right looks like we're good here
donut dally young friends
oh sir cadillion
there he is
all right well we're about down to the
central Hall area so
so we definitely got the one over by
herbology
by the greenhouse
[Music]
sleeping dragon statue
oh I think we got that one
I think we got that one Moon Lily
revelio
that was it oh there's one let's go
just completely wandering around
aimlessly
oh my gosh
oh my gosh I can't believe that worked
we were just literally wandering
and maybe the dragon's the last one
maybe the sleeping dragon
[Music]
let's go we just need one more
dragon fire having a hard time with the
controls it it does take a little bit of
getting used to because it's so
different
it's not like what you would expect them
to fly like
but I feel like I have a pretty good
handle on it now
alohomora
how do you play this game if you're not
in the US uh I mean it's this game
released in a lot of different countries
depends on where you live Alex but
it's available in most most territories
now
oh my goodness this one is
whoa okay this one's at such a weird
spot for both of them
you had a guide up Crossing out the ones
it's helped a lot a nice what do we have
here oh
are gears full
uh
this is annoying I feel like the gear
slots should be a little bit bigger
a little bit bigger
yeah yeah
there we go all right let's take it
tonight again
hey that's the the double benefit of
this I'm gonna recommend that to people
if you want to go after the daily Keys
it's also a great time to go after Demi
guys statues as well yeah degree we got
the history magic one I'm gonna try the
one that Moon Lily just said
this is the other one you told me about
oh did our do we already do that one
though moonly Transfiguration classroom
flu flame oh that's the other one you oh
the one I just got I got you I gotcha
all right so let me just I'm just going
to look through here
oh there's our boy peeves
oh yeah there's the the Gorgon that's
cool
oh that's the painting I was like wait a
second what is that
all right so
let's see
Transfiguration where is the
Transfiguration Courtyard
see I'm telling you guys this is how bad
I am I don't even remember which one we
were at for Transfiguration Courtyard
Ravenclaw Tower
Bell Tower wing
it's literally gonna be the last one
isn't it
yep it's gonna be the last one
my goodness there it is okay
all right Transfiguration classroom oh I
needed to go to the classroom
turn around and go left through the
double doors I'm pretty close to the
classroom though
hold on let's see if I can see if I can
do a chat surely I can get to
no no wait wait
Transfiguration classroom
I think it's this one
nope nope wrong again oh my gosh see
it's bad guys it's really bad
my sense of direction it's so it's so
bad
so very bad all right we're just gonna
go
I'm gonna go straight into the classroom
where is it
okay there's a courtyard
oh wait it's literally right there
all right come on dude surely we can
make that surely we don't need to fast
travel to that
over this way right
yes okay we got it we got it we got it
all right oh my goodness that door just
opened
Weasley is that you
hello revelio
hello
all right so moonly said
turn around and go left through the
double doors okay so we gotta exit this
room right
you can't imagine how inconvenient
travel was before double doors double
doors
all right I need to scroll down you've
probably already told me
oh there it is you posted it again nice
you believe in me
you got the final South Wing page Alicia
let's go
you can use the flu flame list on the
left so you don't have to hover over
each location right yeah yeah that's
what I do but still I feel like like
even when I do that then to know what's
where like like to know where
Transfiguration is
I mean I guess it does tell you in the
little description on that one
can't um imagine I passed it oh no okay
all right so double doors hold on moon
Lily said
all right so there we don't want to go
through there yet right here these
double doors okay okay okay okay
all right we're in we're in revelio
uh go left head straight and then right
down the staircase all the way down
descending by the sleeping Dragon oh my
gosh if this is the last one you guys
this is actually the one
I feel like we did this one okay yeah we
did that one
you said all the way down though
by the sleeping Dragon yeah yeah we did
this one we did this one
yeah we found that one earlier
the puzzle door with the symbols dragon
fire yes you talking about the one with
the numbers
yeah I had a little tip on that in my
video
that I posted on YouTube today
but basically you just have to get the
numbers to add up to the number in the
middle
actually you know what I might have a uh
yeah we'll check trophy room let me show
you guys I'm pretty sure I have a
screenshot
yeah right here is what you need
right there is what you need my friend
who was asking about it
so you just need to know they each
represent a number so it starts at zero
goes all the way to nine the key is
knowing that it starts at zero and then
they just have to add up but yeah if you
watch my video from today
youtube.com well you're here watching
you know you know you know where to find
it
you know where to find it
all right somebody said trophy room I
like that's a good call because
I don't think
yeah that's the one we had that one
count Grizzly with the trophy room
that's a good that's a good call
I don't know which ones oh I see what
you meant earlier Kathy I just need to
look over here
I knew that too why did I not
all right Trophy Room
let's try this one
oh I don't think
oh man I'm getting excited because I
feel like I remember seeing one up here
I do not remember getting one up here
though
all right let's go actually in the
trophy room
okay
got a chest up there oh is that a demi
guys
no looks like a lock
I know they keep what are you up to now
we need it we need to get some new
dialogue added for ignatia
revelio
so is there for sure one up here guys
if it is let me make sure
wait wait I know there's one oh dude
this is the very first one I ever saw
I'm almost positive I have not unlocked
this one almost positive I haven't
isn't it all the way at the top of this
or am I just like wasting my time here
oh no no no this is it dude this is it
yes Rebellion
that's it right
now I just need is there a key
oh this is a Hogwarts secret this is not
no
oh I'm so sad
I'm so sad I knew I I knew for sure I
was like I know there's a door with a
key up here revelio
those are black
well done
I suppose
I don't know but they stopped talking
oh level three
that's right we gotta get the higher
levels to be able to revelio hello there
the Sorting Hat
Enchanted hat was created by the four
founders of Hogwarts as the means by
which students would be placed into one
of the four School houses
skilled at legitimacy the Sorting Hat
can see into the wearer's head allowing
it to determine their thoughts and
abilities oh dude look at the Sorting
Hat look at the Sorting Hat
yeah we'll check we'll check quad
Courtyard next guys sorry I just got
sidetracked
as tends to happen to me in this game
tends to happen
check his desk for a key oh look at you
Kathy look at you
oh and there's a little note here
Apothecary receipt cures for boils
that's right
revelia
oh I'm hearing another one though hold
on
another uh
oh I think we have to have the alohomora
level three
to get higher up
oh not the Dalian just a regular old key
somewhere
I'm missing it guys or maybe did I
already pick it up
oh for for this so that's for the little
teacup right there
and then we read the letter
eating an apple there
ah key is all the way at the top you
need level three to get it okay
yeah I was thinking that
because I went outside I went out here
one day
that's level two but then to get any
higher I'm pretty sure yeah you need
level three right there
and then you also need level three to
get into here as well
all right
Josh's Josh is convinced it's quad quad
Courtyard let's see
all right so
quad Courtyard here we go
let's do this come on please be the one
uh Rye lion not relating to Hogwarts
recently saw video viewers on Eternal
super stoked it's finally coming to PC
hey it's such a good game dude
such a good game revelio
yeah that that video
that I made on returnal has been one of
those like Slow Burn videos more people
keep finding and that one always gets a
lot of like really good comments
and so I I tried it whenever I see
someone comment on that I try to always
go and reply about it
all right Josh I'm here quad Courtyard
let's
let's go on our search old ladies and
Gentlemen let's go
Josh with the win
nice job Josh
all right we're gonna do that next but
first
we getting the final the daily and key
where's the key
key place
lamp place
[Music]
vault 713.
oh I think I see it I think I see it
let's go
go little key go
go little key go we're gonna be rocking
these robes
we're gonna be rocking these new robes
all right nice unlock
oh just gotta say chat just gotta say
Dr sherbet called it out too
from as soon as I figured out what to do
after the first one did not miss a
single slap every single one first try
the reflexes
oh good stuff guys thank you chat shout
out to Moon Lily and Josh especially
Kathy as well
everyone else who was shouting out
suggestions in the chat we got it we got
it now we just have to go back
to Gryffindor Tower
you think I would know where my own
yeah Southland exactly first try I told
you guys it's where we were going
told you
oh go back and talk to the quest Giver
good call
it's Nelly right
all right so now let's see what happens
does it point me in a direction now yeah
probably just over to the chest dude I
always I was wondering what this was
here for
oh this is a special moment you guys
this is a special moment another house
token for the house chest
what if we miscountered
I'm making good progress with those
tokens oh yeah you are
to find the last two for you is coming
along nicely well I did all 16 of them
tonight Dr sherbet so if you go back
and you just like kind of skip through
the Stream
you should be able to find it you know
what that's actually a good video idea I
might like token for the house chest I
might try to go and edit that up and
just put into a video all the daily here
we go okay
time to see what's inside
open
oh my gosh
whoa
well look at that Gryffindor Relic
icon uniform
oh dude all right let's check it out
I've seen the Ravenclaw one the
Ravenclaw one is really nice
hold on hold on we got to get some good
lighting here let's get like over by the
fire yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right let's pull up the gear
okay I think we'll start with the Rope
right
oh Gryffindor Relic House uniform my
house robe for the Brave and true
Gryffindor earned by using the daily
keys to unlock your house chest oh my
gosh dude
I look like
dude this looks like House Lannister or
something
I love the top man
oh let's go now we gotta pick some other
good stuff to go with it though
like in the little icon I was kind of
worried I was like I don't like how it
really looks it looks so dull right here
but dude when you get it on
Victor Crumb I can see that too
now this is like if if uh House
Lannister and house Stark
it's like if the Lannisters ruled the
North in Game of Thrones that's what
this looks like
oh that is so sick
so sick all right now we gotta find
good outfit to go with it
that's actually not bad for the first
try nah not that
quidditch captains uniform
no
he had the PJs right I mean would one of
these look ah no
too much I almost wish it was closed in
the front
I almost wish it was more like Merlin
like like the Merlin one
just completely closes so you don't even
see what what they're wearing underneath
okay that that's not bad right there
that's not bad
oh yeah dragon fire it's uh it's it's
really nice
Diamond jumper school uniform
yeah see I think the back looks awesome
and that's what I'll be seeing most of
the time anyway
all right still not these are like two
oh these are not working for me
hold on hold on hold on that
that's got potential right there
I still want one to just like wow me
this looks like I'm going to a formal
ball or something
I'll have to go play yourself after
seeing that
nice
foreign
we should check and see how many Demi
guys we've got too we might be getting
close on that one
with our boy Gladwin because we probably
found I don't know
three or four Demi guys tonight
oh yeah yeah where where do I find Nelly
is she in the common room
oh dude I'm not loving
I feel like that I feel like that's the
but I don't like the shoes man we
definitely need boots
definitely need some boots on
no Cindy I haven't completed I don't
think I've completed all of them
she's in the Transfiguration where you
first talk to her okay nice I don't know
what do you think chat what do you think
looks best in the front this
I mean that actually that one
I think actually that might be it the
very first one
foreign
especially from the back like I
definitely want it to have the boots
and this one this one kind of goes with
the theme too
and even though it's Gryffindor like
they do they get a little black in there
oh look at look at the robe like move as
you
rotate the character
all right I'm gonna see if there's any
uh
I don't think there'll be a scarf that
will look
nah I don't think you can wear a scarf
with this like because you gotta get
this I mean this part at the top
too good
oh dude hold on hold on hold on
oh man we really want to be in
nah not a mass not a mask what about
like
there's like the Dumbledore Half Moon oh
dude
oh man
nah definitely not the silver
all or the gold the gold half rimmed
the gold rimmed Half Moon spectacles
or the hex
oh dude that looks pretty fire too
I think I'm going with a half moon
though we're going with that
distinguished look
we're going like we're the hero of
Hogwarts ladies and gentlemen
like people need to know
they gotta know who they're talking to
actually whatever these uh whatever the
handwear is is already looking pretty
spot on
wait how do I tell which ones
how do I tell which look I have equipped
or it might just be the look of ornate
ebony gloves I think that's it
just have that look applied
those are already looking pretty good
I'm not switching because I don't want
to switch off if unless I can find these
again
I don't know what they are
unbeatable quidditch gloves
oh there they are ornate ebony
okay let's see if that's it
yeah that's the one okay ornate ebony
I feel like it's pretty I feel like that
one's pretty good yeah I think so Moon
Lily I mean the dark arts are always
oh I don't know that's that's like too
much Gryffindor
I like it I don't love it I feel like
the
yeah yeah I feel like the black
oh good call dreaming good call yeah
yeah if I'm
if I just click off of it yep
oh you could do you could always do like
reset as well I guess yeah I'm gonna
leave that one and let's check on hats I
don't really think I have
I forgot I unlocked that dude
I forgot we unlocked that
nah nah I'm not feeling those
not feeling not feeling any of these
really
oh
the fedora the fedoras got some style to
it
I mean I don't know like the classic let
me Zoom back out
I don't know I don't really think I need
a hat at all
the Hat's alter your hairstyle I guess
my hair is just too short I can't tell
the leather sorcerer for that more uh
that old school vibe
rustic sleeping cap
oh no no no no no no no no
I wore that one for a while I just like
that plain little flat cap there
all right I'm gonna go no hat for now
I'm gonna go no hat we might change our
mind later
oh let's go
let's go all right we gotta go back to
the
Transfiguration Courtyard
which was right here
right here
oh my gosh dude look at the shine
and we're not we're at night right now
too
Nelly hey what do you think about this
yo
look at this
what you did in Cross ones was fantastic
oh wait to wait till you wait until we
talked about that actually check it out
all of the keys the cast of Magic oh so
make your magic more powerful what did
you find
found a rather interesting costume
brilliant costume well thank you for
solving that mystery for me I always
wondered what those keys would be oh
you're you're you're not kidding
dreaming you're not kidding
no
oh my goodness
oh dude
they knew exactly what they were doing
with this
wow
that is so sick
I thought you were just messing around
like now it's gonna make you more
powerful
oh that's too funny all right let's go
check in with our boy Gladwin we'll just
see how many uh
how many we got left
let's see probably right here's gonna be
the fastest to get to him
oh gosh this is so this is so confusing
probably right here
I know Cindy right it's so good
that's never gonna get old
all right Gladwin
that was one of our other goals tonight
was to make some progress on the Demi
guys
which I think we're at 5 out of Thirteen
I know we got at least three at least
three
all right
and I think I think the easiest moons to
find are
the ones out in the hamlets
hello Mr Moon oh dude we are looking
fire anyway
guys statues
I actually have some Moons for you how
many so you have but bring me a few more
and I'll show you how to improve casting
Allah
all right we'll keep looking I'll keep
an eye out for more Demi guys when
you're like the road you were shocked
right I commend you
courage and Valor
especially since it's definitely worth
it that was night
that was for sure worth it I mean it
took what we we've been streaming oh my
gosh we've been streaming three hours
I was about to say treat me like an hour
it was like it took like an hour to find
those we didn't start right away either
so I would say probably a good two two
and a half hours and that was with
people helping me so I can see how it
would take other people a lot longer
if you weren't using a guide or actually
having somebody help you all right dude
we only need three more of these let's
go all right so these I think are even
easier to find if you go out into the
world
because you can just like hover on the
hamlets here
all right so I got that one I'm probably
gonna have to go like further away
because I've gotten most of the ones
close
okay here's one right here we do not
have and look at all these Field Guide
Pages ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls we're gonna find a lot
here let's go
let us go we only need three you guys
three
book
place right when I see one all right so
that should be I was gonna say like
right here
all right and
let's go get the one over here
oh you know what hold on before we do
anything else
let's go sell
again for delivering those potions no
problem nice to see you again dude look
oh my God
we look so stylish
oh man I see you're wearing for sale
what are we looking for today
I just want to
wanna insta selling all the green and
Blues
I'm kind of trying to wait till I get to
level 40 to go and
reveal a lot of these but I still got a
ways to go so I don't know if I'll be
able to wait that long or not
uh yeah I'd be I've beaten the game
dragon I've just been
here tonight with chat we just been
going through doing the extra like side
quests and stuff
so we knocked out the daily in Keys
Quest and what I thought was like an
hour but actually we've been streaming
for three so there you go
actually made a stream of her like three
hours
and yeah let's go ahead and sell you
um might as well go and sell you too
okay that one's an upgrade that was an
upgrade that was an upgrade
all right
thank you stopping in I appreciate it
okay oh no it's turning the morning
I don't want it to turn the morning
because we looking for a demigay statue
well that's for the Merlin puzzle
another Field Guide page
did we not level up yet tonight guys
oh my gosh we've gotten so many Field
Guide pages
uh I'll just say it's pretty it's pretty
cool wubby it's pretty cool
you've been doing Side Quests for over
five hours without any main quests
popping up hmm that's interesting
definitely shouldn't be having to go
that long without a main quest
sounds like uh make sure you've went and
read all of your mail like go in and
read all of your
Outpost stuff
all right so let's go get this last
field guy page and then I'm gonna
Advance it tonight
I just saw it shimmering
yeah yeah make sure you read the mail
all right now let's take it to night
time
yes yeah yeah yeah try that wubby try
that see if that will uh
okay I'm still not sure is it
is it night now
I wonder who lives here sometimes it's
like
I'm not convinced that it's
revelio I guess it should be Knight
all right then where oh there's the Demi
guys look at him guys
there he is just chilling just chilling
in there
wizard PhD what is up
Lynette and all the chatters
welcome welcome in welcome in
hope you all had a wonderful oh my gosh
they're both straight up
let's go
hope you all had a fantastic stream
come on now Demi guys we're just
knocking out some side quests guys so I
don't know if you all are still uh
worried about spoilers or anything we're
not really talking too much story stuff
tonight but look what chat just helped
me hold on hold on let me get let me get
out here in the light so you guys can
see this although it's not really light
right now but I feel like you can see it
a little bit better out here look at
this look at these robes we're rocking
guys
so this is your
completion reward for the daily and keys
Quest based on whichever house you're in
but watch this I thought chat was lying
to me I thought they were lying to me
they said cast your spell NOW Watch What
Happens I'm like oh is it gonna be is my
quote gonna light up or my spell is
going to be more powerful or something
watch this watch this dude
dude it actually freaking lights up
then we had to go with like that
Dumbledore gold half mooned look a real
distinguish right now as soon as we got
these
soon as we started rocking these now we
just need uh two more dimming guy
statues we just got one in here revelio
and we need two more to unlock the next
level of alohomora which will be the
final I think it's the final
I think it is the final
but guys those of you here hanging out
if you haven't checked out wizard phd's
Channel make sure you head on over there
check out her Channel as well make some
awesome Hogwarts Legacy content and she
was also if you watched the recent live
stream that Avalanche did to get your
Merlin cloak then you will know her she
was on there I was just like I was
geeking out watching that Lynette it's
like I know her I know her I've met her
in person now
oh man no in all seriousness though
Lynette you did you did such a fantastic
job
such a fantastic job with that I mean it
was like I felt like you'd been doing
that kind of like hosting thing your
whole life it was which in a way you
have right I mean what we do here online
like this whole streaming thing is a
little bit of that
but yeah you did you did such a great
job obviously representing the community
very well
and also guys if you're wondering why no
uh no camera tonight for any of the new
people who just dropped in I have a
really bad eye infection tonight so
it's like I just it's just better off if
I'm not on camera tonight
I mean it is swollen swole swollen guys
this most swollen most swole that I've
ever seen my eye like and I had black
eyes when I was a kid but yeah it's it's
pretty bad pretty bad
all right so we got one really close
right here we just need two more Demi
guys let's go to felcroft right here
da
I've always said that you think I need a
top hat Moon Lily I don't know
I don't know I don't think I didn't
really try much of the top hats though
did I oh I see you Demi guys right off
the Jump
right off the Jump coming for you to me
guys
oh and it requires a level two
glad we already had that
open sesame the bowler head
fine now Demi guys mine now indeed Demi
guys all right we just need one more
guys
we just need one more but while we're
here might as well open the chests
without any more I thought there was
yeah
huge decorated table
see I know Alicia wanted to see the
animals getting fed but you don't have
to worry now Alicia I got the little
automatic
the animals are being well taken care of
don't worry
don't you worry
oh dude and we're getting new wands
new one handles I should say
an intruder
hold on I'm about to show chat my new
combo revelio
dude this combo absolutely rips where
they at you gonna talk and not not do
anything oh there you are you're all the
way down there like yelling intruder
okay wait hold on Buddy hold on you're
that far I thought you were like right
beside me
if you're that far then I'm just gonna
go ahead and open this loot
don't mind me
oh this is a legendary one too let's go
unidentified neck item
Rock The Pumpkin hat don't don't do this
to me chat we're looking so fire right
now
we're looking so fire it's like a place
right out of a storybook right I hope
they don't get mad for me doing this
guys I'm doing this for the trophy
oh dude they they get mad
they get mad
don't get mad guys it's for a trophy
it's just for a trophy
yeah yeah yeah cow tipping cow tipping
with for pindo oh there's another one
over here
see they're cool with it they're cool
like they're all right hey you ready
buddy you ready it's gonna be fun all
right
oh no you didn't make it
do I have to get them all the way
I'm sorry okay don't be mad
all right that was like three or four we
did right there
flippindo
revelio
see I'm already here so I'm like I might
as well do it what did the cow do to you
the cow was a barrier to a trophy
that's what the cow did
right in
hold on
where'd it go
oh I had it it's gone
there we go okay got that one
right there
all for the trophy
indeed
nice another wand handle
all right let's we just need one more
Demi guys
but they all say
that's what they all say
and I think there's one here
let me go ahead and Mark you
and looks like our closest travel Point
probably gonna be here
I wonder if somebody got that without
looking
you're waiting for the new stream hey
we've been streaming we've been
streaming
yeah yeah you'll have to check the uh so
if you check the live page on YouTube
we've been streaming some here and then
we've also been streaming some over on
Twitch so twitch.tv retro reckon tour
you can find the vods there
and then we've done a couple of streams
over here for the game too
doing the companion quest uh I did not
finish them but I will I will do them
probably not tonight
but I do plan on doing the companion
Quest yeah also Demi guys in the three
Broomsticks
nice we just I think we just need one
more Moon Lily so we should be good
actually
I mean I'll obviously want to get them
all for the trophy but revelio
but
right now I just wanted to get them all
oh there he is there he is
mine now demigod
fascinating truly fascinating who shot
the energy oh my gosh
you're not creepy at all just like
sitting out here sipping your tea late
at night
all right Demi guys where you at
oh dude this one he was actually hiding
he was actually hiding
hiding behind the little cabinet
Alden how's it going welcome
yeah it was almost perfect timing mine
now dimming guys all right we're already
here we might as well unlock this flu
flame
oh my goodness and yeah you guys saw
that sweet little innocent cow up here
okay I'm very sorry for this I'm very
sorry
okay you're already standing so
whoa that one has the power of
deflection I don't know if that one
counted
I think we have to do it again Chad I
don't know if it counted
there we go all right
let's see how many more do we need I
think you need 10 total it's probably
what five
any more cows in the area
any more cows
wow Moon Lily says
guys it's a trophy I'm sorry promise I
promise once we've once we're done once
we get the trophy
it's all taking care of the magical
creatures from there I mean I like to
imagine flippindo
it just sets them down gently you know
just nice and gentle
oh can you do it on the same cow
Dr sherbet don't tell me that they'll
tell me that I'll just stay
I'll just stand there and do it on the
same cow
use the same cow oh my gosh all right
okay sorry to the cow because here we
come we're coming back
all right right here
all right buddy I promise we'll make it
we'll make it snap
oh my gosh that was that was violent
right there
there we go spilled milk okay
oh dude I didn't think he was gonna get
up
I did not think it was gonna get up okay
can I like I don't know here can I feed
you or something okay you just want me
to leave fair enough fair enough
watch this guys never have to fall to
your death in this game
never have to fall to your death if you
can if you can very quickly pull out the
broom
all right now I I say this I gotta make
sure I don't mess this up all right
oh
every time every time
all right we're not gonna fly all the
way back though
our buddy Gladwin Moon where are you at
my friend
greeting
hold on he's not marked anymore
he's marked
greetings
oh right here maybe
all right let us go and find Mr Moon
I'm actually really I'm excited for this
there's been a very productive stream
guys maybe I should do no cam more often
I don't know if that's the reason or if
you guys have just been like in super
helpful
engaging
we have gotten a lot done tonight got
all we just completely knocked out the
daily and keys and we're about to
upgrade our
alohomora all the way to level three
all right Gladwin
teach me that final level three version
because we're ready to and I think the
first thing I'm gonna do is we're gonna
do the
I have to do the headmaster's office
because that's what I'm most curious
about that key you guys were talking
about
I'm so intrigued now
I'm so intrigued all right Gladwin here
we go dude hello Mr Moon
greetings huh any luck removing some
more of those Demi guys statues yes
we've had more luck with the demigod
statues I actually have some Moons for
you dear me you have been busy
incredible thank you
you're ready for the
block show ever stand in your way that's
what I'm talking about all I asked I
only wish I knew put those
hey we'll keep looking because there's
more alas
if you do find more please feel free to
remove them you'll be doing your
caretaker a huge service
and if I ever find out who the bully is
behind this cruel trick I shall let you
know I want to know thank you once again
for
assistance and tenacity
wait you don't teach me you just did
Allah no lock is unbreakable but do feel
free to keep finding demigodai statues
and removing those moons
wait is this your cat too is this like
your Mrs Norris no way
no way right
all right that was incredibly productive
it's a pretty funny story when you find
out oh see I wanna how do you find out
Kathy is it do you have to collect them
all before you find out is that the only
way
oh yeah trophy room to get to the
Headmasters quarters quickly
good call
that's where I want to go
he will send you an owl
talk to again Hogs me
ah okay
so it's just like it'll happen naturally
like he'll
he'll reach out
or do I have to keep finding more oh the
culprit will send you an owl ah
nice
yeah yeah no spoilers I wanna I wanna
see
I want to find out on my own that'll be
funny
all right wait I'm going the wrong way
aren't I
or no this is I think this is the right
way
this way
all right
no more secrets Phineas
no more secrets
we got the hero of Hogwarts in here
rocking our Gryffindor robes
with the level three alohomoro lock pick
all right so I think
all right I'm gonna do this one first
because I think this is a trophy
for going to the highest point
none of them
usually always get one just like right
away
and then once you unlock that one maybe
that's for all the Demi guys and then
you have no more lock picking game
it just insta
there it is Room with a View
revelio
you gotta come up here in the day
Professor black regarding your letter
dated 20th of September I shall not
reconsider the admissions process at
Hogwarts regards Ferris baven so that's
almost certainly a letter Phineas scent
in reference to blood status because he
held to
slytherin's belief
of pure Bloods only
there's the key of admittance oh my gosh
the key of admittance no way revelio
all right
I gotta see where that key leads now
I gotta see where the key leads
and I know we got to come back for that
spot too
all right down we go down we go down we
go
oh my gosh I'm getting a little dizzy
actually from this
what's in here dude I honestly have no
idea I knew that the daily and key
reward I have no idea what's behind here
wait I'm supposed to be doing something
oh my gosh
quite a few locks here oh okay we get a
legendary chest solve Hogwarts secrets
all right nice unidentified outfit item
I'm not looking at chat because I don't
want anybody to tell me what it is
probably not gonna be as cool as these
robes though is it
probably not as cool as the robes it
didn't involve I mean it kind of did
involve as much
oh
remote acceptance
oh my gosh the cool of acceptance the
book of admins were placed here by the
founders and have not been touched since
they record the name of every
perspective Hogwarts student the moment
they first show signs of magic although
the quill is more lenient than the book
which will sometimes snap shut before a
name is written if the evidence of magic
is not dramatic enough okay that's cool
another one handle
large rugs all right not as cool as the
robes but just like lore wise man that
is really cool
that is really cool to get to see that
pretty awesome
wow
all right I'm gonna go here and I'm
gonna take a look at the gear I want to
spin my character around I'm just gonna
get a screenshot of that right there
might be useful in like a thumbnail at
some point a YouTube thumbnail
yeah very cool lore wise
somebody's saying something about the
wallpaper oh yeah
so you've got each house represented of
course you got Gryffindor Ravenclaw
they're Slytherin there's Hufflepuff
[Music]
that is so cool man oh you got the
Phoenix right here
dragon
estral
wow
all right man I think we're gonna wrap
it there guys this has been great though
this has been great how many oh yeah
yeah good question right before we end
so I think
I think what it says right here is not
accurate guys because I know
what it says right here I'm going to
save over the second one
I know it's more than 45.
so let me check if I go into the PS5
hold on I always forget where it is on
PS5
to go to my
trophies here
and then I think here
doesn't it show you
I thought there was a place that it
shows you how many
how many hours
oh well I'll find it later but yeah so I
mean I'm I'm 45 hours but I think it's
more I think it's probably more like 55
60 somewhere in there
guys thank you all so much for being
here
um
super fun super fun
in your profile and go to your games uh
okay
let's see here
okay profile
[Music]
oh games here we go here we go dude 10.
what the heck
it's been way more than 10 hours okay
well I know that's incorrect
what in the world dude how's it gonna
say 10 hours
I don't know why I wouldn't have updated
very bizarre
all right anyway thank you all so much
for the likes for the follows uh for the
subs and also for the super chats very
much appreciated very much appreciated
if you're not in our Discord you can
check that out as well but we'll have
more videos coming this week guys more
live streams coming this week as well so
stay tuned if you're not in the Discord
or not follow me on Twitter those are
the best two places to know uh when
we're gonna go live I think it only
counts if you're connected P I said oh I
may still be disconnected because I uh
well no I should be connected to PSA
I'll take a look at it later who knows I
know 10 hours right
right
oh dude
all right guys thank you all for being
here everybody have a fantastic evening
and I will talk to you again soon later
guys
[Music]